She's an amazing human being and she is caring...
...and she also happens to be one of the smartest people I've ever met.
And she's got a great sense of humor.
There's a number of reasons why, but she does do some of the things she takes on.
And I've always been very proud of her...
...when I see her speaking at the International Court of Appeals...
...in Strasbourg with her robe on.
Pretty impressive.
Very impressive.
What you think about her becoming such a fashion icon?
She's always, since the day I met her, she's always had this insanely,...
...it's eccentric but it's fun, sense of fashion.
It has been sort of fascinating to watch and see...
...because she has such great taste.